see quite a bit of damage i saw
walking out this morning the first two
vehicles i saw were tree trucks
oh yeah overturned trees broken up limbs
you know things a lot of plastic trash
bags we had a little moment of silence
for the tree in the eight parking lot
that i know
also hit the dust thankfully it fell
away from cars and towards the lawn let
me honestly i'm gonna miss that tree
that was a huge tree and it gave great
shade yes that's what i mean for our
cars
and
to try to get that big it's been taken
years i gotta be honest ted i didn't
know you were that tied to the tree no i
won't expect i really am
you know how many times i've eaten lunch
under that tree right
you always find ted there with his pb
a live look outside right now guys hey
big difference from yesterday right
where we look at these tower cams and
you can even see the mountains now
things have cleared up with those
northerly winds the winds also calmed
down quite a bit too so we're all happy
about that now one thing we want to let
you know about because sally didn't get
a chance to touch into this because she
was covering that story lee canyon
picked up seven inches of new snow kyle
canyon five inches above 8 800 feet
those are those mountain tops right
above the ski lifts 10 to 11 inches of
snow and for las vegas we just picked up
a trace of rain officially but some
neighborhoods like anthon picked up two
tenths of an inch down at mountains edge
four hundredths of an inch the high
today 64 degrees it's not official but
that's what we have so far 83
is our average so we're not even going
to reach 70 today 97 is the record that
was set back in 1950 so currently
outside we start off in the northwest
centennial hills 65 60 for you in
summerlin 66 downtown 65 green valley
763 64 for henderson and roads ranch
mountain's edge at 62. temperatures of
course way below normal for this time of
the year 60 for indian spring 70 for
lofland 64 for boulder city since we
didn't get as warm today prepare for a
cold
cold morning in fact it's actually
warmer in new york than here look at 64
for us look at the big apple 68 chicago
just slightly cooler than us not a huge
drop look at that 65 for boston warmer
than us so that low continues to spin
off towards the east leaving behind that
cold front pass through leave behind
colder temperatures
behind that front and tomorrow's winds
should stay nice and light for tomorrow
too so that's good those winds pretty
much have ended this afternoon at least
calm down we'll see lighter winds also
for tomorrow so this is the other big
story okay tomorrow morning you're
definitely going to need to bundle up
because this is the coldest temperatures
we haven't seen in months and also the
coldest temperatures this week 42 and
somewhere tomorrow morning 43 for anthem
saint rose parkway 47 downtown
45 for henderson and i'll post this on
social for you too let's just share with
everybody 36 for prom boulder city 46
overnight 47 officially cold and clear
lighter winds for tonight tomorrow 67
unseasonably cool because we should be
at 83 for this time of the year here's
your eight day forecast we're going to
stay in the low 70's through the rest of
the work week warm it up but still
remain comfortable for the weekend next
week still looking at low 80's
for fall it's going to feel like it
brian we'll send it to you all right ted
thank you